okay so here we are I saw a viral video
of a giant wheel of cheese that was
melted on top and then just jumped on to
a bunch of like potatoes
what and Adam asked me to make it Adam
first off we need the cheese I called a
bunch of cheese shops I know I'm nuking
400 high do you think this is gonna go
well he's shaking his head no stead of
getting half wheel we got a whole wheel
because why not supposed to be 9 pounds
which doesn't sound that heavy to me but
that's how much a baby weighs there is
it this is fancy smells like farts this
was more than we even anticipated and it
was 324 dollars for 10 pounds of cheese
which is a lot of money for cheese oh my
god also I'm lactose intolerance this is
gonna be great cheese wheel whoo oh damn
the hell oh it comes with a whole set of
stickers Oh aged a minimum of 90 days
fancy which reminds me we have to make
something to put this on top of what
I've researched very vaguely and very
quickly is that it's typically over
boiled potatoes so we're doing red
potatoes because that's what the grocery
store had how do you peel potatoes do
the wet oh okay cool I am for sure gonna
hurt myself
okay we're gonna set these bad boys now
gotta cut this cheese in the video it's
only a half a wheel of cheese they do it
oh my god
now oh I know that I think oh my god I
went on a cheese trip it smells so bad
it smells like oh it was like a thousand
parts all right where was i but in the
videos cut in half how does one go about
cutting a giant wheel of cheese oh it's
not okay it's very thick god this is
only a semi-soft cheese you gotta use
all your bodyweight smells so bad oh
it's wild that we even made or ate
cheese with how bad it smells whew so
smooth cheers hands I'm gonna have to
just get used to it okay I'm gonna try a
little bit of it cuz I'm curious I don't
know if I like it I'm gonna give some to
Adam there you go it's very sharp oh
this is boiling over the top
Oh done voila so I'm gonna salt and
pepper my potatoes get them prepped we
don't have an open fire so I'm going to
attempt to blowtorch the side of this
how do you work this thing
don't play a fire at home okay I think
this is gonna work but is this just
putting like straight-up butane onto
some cheese that you're gonna eat start
from the top
oh wow it's bubbling this is the
craziest thing I've ever done in my life
besides meeting a Spice Girl oh it
smells so much better now so in the
video they kind of oh okay that wasn't
perfect oh it's like a cheetah skin it
smells very charred mmm okay so when I
first tried this it was like very sour
goes from being tart to being much more
rich in flavor so good right okay we
need to melt even more all right there
are specialty pieces of equipment that
you're supposed to use to melt this
cheese but there are like an additional
$300.00 gonna use an iron with a
hairdryer and then I'm gonna toast it
off and then try and melt it on there
you can see the Middle's bubbling a lot
Oh
oh my god I think that works way better
that is so good
should we bring people in here to try it
this is real
I've just been yes hundred dollar hard
time
do you think there's a better way to
melt it think maybe you can put in a
broiler moving on alright we are going
to broil this bad boy beginning start to
while their part is broiling I'm gonna
get to set up the potatoes we've invited
everyone to come up here
[Music]
wait get out of like it I okay guys all
right and now we scrape it
all right we've tried three different
ways to make this raclette the most fun
was with an iron and a hairdryer the
most successful was with a broiler I
would definitely recommend having the
cheese at some point in your life and
what do you guys think is it good yeah
until next time it'll be not me in the
next episode yeah yeah we got it we got
to melt it and then it's bad when it's
not melted oh yes
[Music]